if i'm not mistaken this man was
literally the first person that
you guys asked to surprise me with a
phone call on my birthday correct
because you know what this is means to
me you know what this man means to me
the being a native new yorker
and loving this man and how he carried
himself and did his business for all
those years with the yankees
now a manager of the miami marlins kind
enough to call in a few days later
uh with his marlins taking on the
phillies later on today uh
in philadelphia donald arthur mattingly
joining me here on the rich eisen show
how are you don mattingly
hey rich how are you i am fine i'm
always better for talking to you
how are you doing i'm doing good
yeah we're hanging in there um this
division's a little crazy
have been pretty good consistent they've
probably been the one team that's been
consistent in our division
i think there have been we played good
for a few games
and we played bad for a few games so you
know
hoping they come down to earth and and
we get hot
well one of the things i wanted to hit
you about uh talking about
uh you know this season and was a
comment that you made in
a couple of weeks ago a few weeks ago
now and this is the first time i've
gotten a chance to talk to you
um where you know we were talking about
all of the
all of the no-hitters and the lack of
hitting in major league baseball and the
number of strikeouts and the shift
taking hits away
and how things are working you use the
word uh unwatchable
um you know not saying it's all
unwatchable but on occasion unwatchable
uh what what did you what did you mean
by that when you said that
don a few weeks ago yeah without being
the guy that i don't want to be the guy
that's fashioned
you know through the hitting but it's
just it's i think as a general fan
of the game just like there's times when
nothing goes on
and and i really was referencing me
watching like parts of the world series
last year
i remember watching like i think the
last i don't know two innings or
something like that it was like
there was like one ball put in play and
it's like
that's tough to watch for me and uh i
i was really referencing more from a
fan's point of view my point of view
watching it on tv you feel like you
could walk
back and catch the game right back where
it was
and nothing really went on so if i i
think that's a problem and i think
mlb is really addressing that problem
and talking about ways to bring we have
to have action we have to have
a game that people like watching so what
would you do
uh don uh what would you do if i if i
you know
said uh you know what you would suggest
would be implemented by baseball
to to incur some action on that front
what would that be for you
yeah i think you i think some of the
things that they're trying and trying to
get the data on
uh ways to open up the stolen base again
uh where you you have more opportunity
they're talking about making the base
just like a
just a little bit bigger which just
shortens the routes just a little bit
i think you got we have to encourage
like action in the game
as far as being rewarded for putting the
ball in play
you know and i hate that you know
there's certain things i don't like
that like eliminating some of the
shifting
oh uh i and i know you do the nfl and i
look at that like eliminating the shift
is like telling the defense you can't
play this way you got to use only
three linebackers and you got to use
only three defensive you know but
however many defensive backs and
everybody else has to be online
scrimmage
uh like so that that's where shifting
like drives me crazy because i think
this has been a problem
it's been coming for a long time right
it started
you know probably 15 years ago where the
strikeout began to get devalued
uh and once you start devaluing that it
just became like a strikeouts and out
and next thing you know it's it's 20 at
night
right and there's you know we were
striking out probably i felt like 12 14
times a night
we only get 27 outs and it's like
there's 13 other chances to try to score
and so i think there's got to be ways to
put things where we
where incentivizing you know stolen base
a guy that can put the ball a different
way of thinking about the game
as far as you know just all of the the
three run homer and
and don't matter if you strike out
things like that well i mean and
in terms of the shift that you bring up
don mattingly manager of the miami
marlins here on the rich eisen show
um when you brought up the nfl the nfl
when there was a big problem with points
on the board and
you remember mel blunt uh from the
pittsburgh steelers
don and he basically because he was such
a huge uh player not just
in terms of talent but in terms of
height and weight
and how he could move at that position
and he was such a game changer like
literally whenever i see him at the hall
of fame it does look like he could still
give me 10 snaps don they they did
change the rule
where you had to they they did change
the way that you could play defense and
and and be penalized for touching
somebody in a certain way
at a certain you know uh amount of yards
uh
from the line of scrimmage i mean they
did change it and so
there are rules as to how you can play
defense without being penalized for it
and i
i would love to see you know if you are
uh in the lineup card as a shortstop or
a second baseman or a third baseman
there's only one side of the field that
you're allowed to be on that's it
and i'm wondering if would you would you
take that as somebody who does know
the value of placing people in a certain
spot on the field
don yeah i think that's fair
and i think that's really i mean if
you've been following it all
like theo epstein has become a part of
mlb and that's doing a lot of they're
doing a lot of studies on
the ships and uh you know the bases
you know moving the mound back you know
not changing the strike zone but making
it automated where the guys know the
strike zone
uh and i think you're right we have to
do some things that make the game
more it's like any you know you talk
about the nfl i watch basketball too so
like
nba you can't touch anybody anymore
right you can't bump you can't arm check
you can't hand check
and so now that becomes like an often
more of an offensive thing that people
like
so i think there's a lot going on that
says hey we've got to be
more a game that fans enjoy
and all the other all leagues seem like
they change rules and
and things to you know tweak the game to
make it a better game
um to watch at least for for the fans
and i know everybody fights that
sometimes the
the old school is like oh we can't
change the game
but i think you have to you have to stay
with the times and
and be current don mattingly here on the
rich eisen show and one of the many
reasons why i loved watching you play
don
was you could hit to all fields you get
to all fields with power and
striking out to you was something that
was
um a major negative like it was
something that
that it was a rarity to see because you
could put the ball in play
and you know there was a stigma to it
and
what how do you speak to a player today
now as somebody who can counsel this
sort of thing
about cutting down on strikeouts and
valuing
putting the ball in play what how do you
coach it how do you manage it
don well you you
it's something you can't talk about but
you know honestly
that this has been uh something that's
going on with all organizations where
they have devalued the strikeout
over time and i think it's coming back
where there's
there is value to putting the ball more
value put on putting the ball in play
but like anything else we got a reward
you know
guys know they go to arbitration and you
get in that salary process
that if you're you know putting the ball
in play more but you're not hitting the
ball out of the ballpark
you're not doing any damage you're not
you're worth
goes down so we don't value it as an as
a
industry so when you start putting value
on putting the ball in play
and moving a runner over and and and
guys that don't strike out as much
are there is a value to that when that
starts happening you got a better chance
of getting more players like that
that believe in that but right now i
mean organizations basically
teach get the ball in the air uh
launch angle exit velocity that's all
they you hear a lot of that
now though there is movement towards
more contact
you know swing in the zone uh guys that
make contact with the ball in the zone
there's all kinds of stats obviously in
every sport
but those are all stats but if you don't
value them
contract wise guys aren't going to
change
right you've already you we've been
doing this for 10 12 years now so the
kids coming up
high school and college they look just
like the pros
and they're swinging up and they're
punching out and
that's just the game they grew up in
what do you think of uh the check-in
pictures how do you think that's going
first couple weeks of that now or in the
second full week of it don
how do you think you know i think it's
it's went well
uh i think it's something that had to
happen i was i think i was a little
naive
on it i was a little naive on the
steroids too honestly i was thinking oh
there's not
many guys doing it and obviously we
found out there was a lot of guys doing
it
and i think what happened with the
sticky stuff because it came it really
started with players basically i mean
everybody's always tried to have a
little bit of
of tack on the ball and players in
general would say
hey i don't mind you know i want a guy
to have some kind of grip i don't want
to get hit in the head right i wanted to
know where it's going
and i think that got taken to another
level yeah
and that's really what happened where it
when you heard more and more guys coming
back
on that ball's not moving naturally
you know you grow up in a game that you
see the ball move and where it's
supposed to go it starts one spot
it's going to another and when balls
start going places they shouldn't go to
unnaturally it's like i don't know what
to do with that
right and so player you heard more and
more players coming back
saying that thing's moving in a way i've
never seen a ball move before
and that told told us that the pitchers
were
going too far right they've taken it to
an advantage now they take it from
okay yeah i need a little grip okay
we're all good with that a little
sunscreen rosin or whatever
and that turned into super glue where
you could hear that you could actually
hear the baseball coming off guys
no kidding when they would throw it you
would hear
it's like it was amazing and then you
know they nowadays they can check spin
rates guys were having spin rates that
were
past their prime numbers ever
right so they just kept going up and up
which creates it makes it tougher and
tougher to hit so
i think hitters just got fed up with it
and and i think it's a good thing
and and we're going to stay on it
because it won't be long the guys are
going to
they're going to start giving up some
hits and and getting hit harder
and they'll be trying to find ways to to
use it again
no kidding so you're saying you're
you're in the dugout i mean you've
you can see the way ball moves too from
there and you would you'd talk to your
hitters as they come back and you'd
you'd have a quick confab
and agree with each other like that that
is not
right there is something up with that
that's what you're saying
you'd have those moments yeah absolutely
absolutely and for me not necessarily
being able to see that movement because
i'm not up there these guys see it right
but obviously you hear it and
and that's what's amazing and then we'd
get balls back into the dugout on the
foul ball the empire throws it out
and it it was like so sticky that you
could i remember a guy and i'm not going
to use his name because it's been out
there too many times anyway
right that the ball came back
i got some on my finger and it was
almost like when you use super glue and
you glue something and inevitably you
always get that on your fingers right
and i couldn't hardly get it off it took
me like two innings of peeling at my
finger to get this stuff off of my hand
so i i i was like this is a whole nother
level of sticky
right and guys were just using it to it
to an advantage to an athletic advantage
and and really kind in a sense like
steroids right you're using that
people don't want to know about a guy
that is using super glue to get a better
breaking ball they want to know a guy
that's
actually got a good breaking ball
because it's him so um
when you say they got a stake stay on it
because it does seem to me though
allowing you as a manager don mattingly
here on the rich hazard show allowing
you as a manager to have the right
to ask somebody to be checked in the
middle of an inning similar to what
happened with
girardi and scherzer the other day that
there's got to be
something about that or do you as a
manager appreciate having the ability to
go to
an ump at any point in time and say
check that guy
yeah i think i think what's happened is
it it's gotten to be where they're going
to check
in between innings you know they check
two to three times a game on the starter
every reliever gets checked when he's
coming off the field it hasn't been a
big thing but it's it's getting to be
i'm afraid that it gets to be like so
quick and so nonchalant that
guys figure a way to do it but now it
does open up the door for a manager
because
it's always been available to you as a
manager to check a guy
but you also knew that you probably had
some guys on your club that were using
some type of something
that you were all sudden this was going
to be back and forth
with them checking your guys and you
checking their guys
so it was almost like an unwritten that
you
you're not really going to check right
it's totally obvious a guy's got
you know a big old patch on his arm or
hand
then you you could you would do it but
in general you weren't doing it
now i think it's opened the door to be
able to say hey we think this guy's
because your video guys are getting it
too
our video guy's sitting back there
watching this thing he's like okay he's
going to his neck
every time right to the ball right so
now you can go out and say hey
our guys got this guy going right to his
neck into the ball
you're able to do that now and i think
it's it's going to be accepted that you
can do that
instead of it being a back and forth
between teams
this is wild this is crazy that that's
not what you signed up for either is it
don i mean you know
you just want to manage some ball and it
just seems like you know
there's a lot of things you know there's
a lot of things you know
that you don't sign up for but you know
what that it all comes with the
territory
and it's you know what's the evolution
of of sports in different
ways right i mean you see it all the
time you got guys with ipads you're able
to watch
pictures pitch in between innings and
you can see what you know plays in
between these just like
i watched on the i you know i watched
sunday football like a lot of other
people
and you see the guys looking at ipads
and where the plays are and what was
open and where i could have went
differently and
so you have all that instantly and so
you you do evolve as a sport
and and that part is it's kind of
actually fun and challenging to be able
to keep evolving with that
before i let you go tell me about uh
mattingly charities how's your
charitable work going
don and how could people get involved
and fill up your coffers
what do you got for me there yeah i
appreciate you asking rich
again i know we've talked about this in
the past and obviously this last
year or probably you know during the
pandemic has been a tough year for a lot
of non-profits
we were we were lucky in a sense because
of the tops came out with a crazy card
that ended up making us a bunch of money
as a charity
um but it's for underserved youth uh
it's for kids in the worst situations uh
it's turned into more educational than
anything we
we've done sports we we we support
reading programs we've
we've put in stem labs um you know
support
you know different athletic you know
things that's going on for kids summer
camps it's really a way to
hopefully help our communities uh just
get stronger
and for the kids that kind of have
fallen through the cracks to make sure
they know
that there are some choices to make and
you know they have to make them
but you want them to know there's
available choices to make if they're
willing to work for them and
and there is places to go and that's
really what our our mission has been
is to really reach those kids that
aren't getting
uh or don't even know about the services
right and there's opportunities for them
they just have to make those choices
and mattinglycharities.org for people to
learn more
and donate and and uh learn how they can
be part of
what you're doing um i i really
appreciate the call donna
i love our chats i cherish them quite
honestly and
uh my s now soon-to-be eight-year-old
daughter
would be livid if she knew that i had
you on and i did not send you her best
since her middle name is your last name
as you know don i think
so she says her best i do know that and
i appreciate you don't know how much
that means to me really honestly i've
had some different families
uh traveling around that well it's
mostly little girls it seems like
not too many boys uh which is cool it's
but i have evolved from dogs and cats
you know some little girls yes it's kind
of cool
but i i seriously i am always you know
you're humbled by that
that somebody likes you enough and
respects you enough to
oh yeah you know obviously kids are
special to all families
to put your name on them is is really is
a humbling thing for me
yes and it also because her first name
is taylor which is fascinating enough
one of your
is your son's name right taylor um so um
her her name is taylor maddingly eisen
and because of your middle name
her her initials are literally tme isn't
too much eisen which she is
don and she hits to all fields she hits
to all fields
she makes contact where she's she can
catch she can throw she can do it all
she's literally a five tool player
my daughter so you should be proud of
that we're gonna keep make her be an
athlete
i love it meet athletes absolutely
absolutely and she
just like her dad she complains about
the shift so it's all good we're all
we're all part of the same family
thanks for the call don i really
appreciate it you'd be well we'll let's
touch base down the road
please that sounds good richard really
appreciate it you got it that's
don mattingly don mattingly number 23.
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here